miss peregrine's home for peculiar
children is directed by Tim Burton based
on the novel by ransom Riggs adapted
into screenplay form by Jane Goldman and
this is a story of Professor Xavier
school for gifted youngsters and stars
asa butterfield as the boy who stumbles
across this school in the 40s I'm just
going to keep calling it Xavier school
for gifted youngsters because I find it
hard to say the word peculiar so a young
boy named Jake played by Asa Butterfield
loses his grandfather in death and his
grandpa always talked to him about this
strange school where kids could go to
feel safe if they had something that was
strange or different about them for they
had some sort of ability
this kid has very absent-minded parents
who don't really pay attention to him
and one day he stumbles through a cave
system that leads him to this school in
the 1940s and from there on our
adventure begins Tim Burton is a
director who is very hit and miss for me
he's made some great films some films
I've loved some films I've liked and
then some that is kind of like mm no mm
no I was looking forward to this movie
though because to me it looked like a
cross between x-men and Harry Potter and
these two things combined and it made me
excited you know it made my little nerd
isms very happy this movie has all of
the typical great Tim Burton Flair
amazing production design terrific
visuals everything looks and sounds
great it even has a Danny Elfman score
that's not actually composed by Danny
Elfman it sounds just like Danny Elfman
I guess he wasn't able to compose for
this movie the performances are all
great I really liked Eva green as miss
Peregrine's she was suitably
over-the-top
she said everything very fast and very
astute she was just so proper and I
really liked her character quite a bit
and as for all the kids at this school
with their strange abilities and all the
cool things they could do some were
really fun some were just adorable and
then others like the character Enoch was
just extremely annoying and grating and
that character really got on my nerves
but I unfortunately found that the
characters I was most interested in in
this school were the ones that got the
least amount of screen time the twins I
want to know what they were all about
there's a girl named Claire who has a
mouth on the back of her head she was
adorable
really funny and there's a little girl
in the movie who is like the strongest
little girl on the planet she can move
boulders and do everything with ease and
I love that character too unfortunately
the best kids at this school and the
ones that I found the most intriguing
were the ones that got the least amount
of screen time and that was
disappointing to me because the
characters that got more screen time to
me were the ones I was like oh they're
cool you know she can blow air I guess
really fast and she can touch things and
light things on fire
but unfortunately my biggest issue with
this movie is our main character Jake
it's not a sub utter filled he is mostly
pretty good in this movie there are a
few scenes one in particular in a boat
underwater where I felt he was just
totally off I don't know what happened
on that day of filming but for the most
part he's really good in the movie it's
the character Jake that is vastly boring
he spends almost the entire film doing
nothing but asking questions and someone
will explain something to him because
he's obviously very interested in this
world and all these amazing things that
he's discovering and all these stories
that his grandpa told him ever since he
was a kid are suddenly coming true
before his eyes
so obviously anybody would have a lot of
questions but unfortunately he spends
the entire film doing nothing but asking
questions and just kind of walking
around going wow I mean imagine if Harry
Potter just spent all of Sorcerer's
Stone just asking people questions you
never see him in class learning about
magic you never see him harmony and Ron
going out on some form of an adventure
you never see him actually playing
Quidditch you just hear him asking
people about Quidditch you hear him
asking people about how their wands work
about how to cast a spell you never
actually see him doing any of these
things Jake in this film eventually
grabs a crossbow and shoots a few arrows
but he really doesn't do much of
anything until the final 20 to 30
minutes and he's a very boring
protagonist also the film started out
really good I actually really liked the
first act of this movie and as he gets
into this place
and he discovers this time loop and
everything starts happening in front of
his eyes I was like this is cool I was
really getting into but I liked the
fantastical element of it I loved the
visual style and then for whatever
reason at the end of that day he decides
to go back to the present with his
boring ass father at a hotel somewhere
the entire film ground to a halt for me
at this
I mean imagine if Luke Skywalker he gets
on the Millennium Falcon he's heading to
the Death Star he gets in the deaths are
like Oh shed this is getting cool and
then he just goes back to Tatooine for a
while why would you do that or if
Chihiro from spirited away after she
learns of this cool world and she's
learning about spirits and witches and
monsters and she's experiencing all
these great things she goes back on that
walk with her parents it's like we've
already been exposed to the really cool
part of this movie why would you go back
to the part that was earlier that was
kind of like let's get to the cool stuff
you know if that's in the novel which I
have not read I can understand why they
would try to keep that in this film but
I'm reviewing the movie not the book in
this movie this is a very scatterbrained
plot that eventually gets very very
messy and also very convenient people
just appear and say hey if you do this
then you can do that and then we'll have
that and everything will be fine it's
like what what how that happened like
it's hard to explain without spoiling
anything but towards the end of the
movie certain things happen and you're
like how did that even eventually one of
my favorite actors the one and only
samuel l.jackson shows up looking like a
demonic version of Don King is sort of
just fun because he samuel l.jackson I
really didn't get his character it's
such a random backstory it has to do
with eyeballs and ingesting them and
certain things occur after these
eyeballs are ingested and it's just it's
so I just don't know if it really worked
the film is going for a really cool
fantasy vibe and Tim Burton is able to
accomplish a lot of that but
unfortunately a very boring protagonist
and a story that jumps all over the
place from at one point being very
interesting to another just being like
get back to the school please all these
things led to a sometimes entertaining
film with great production design mostly
good direction some good performances
but a very very muddled and messy story
I'm going to give it a see I was
disappointed in this film I think it
could have done a lot more
sometimes novels just don't translate
well to film this happens a lot we've
seen it happen a lot and perhaps if they
do decide to make the other two books in
this trilogy please first of all
actually make it a trilogy don't make
or films I beg you I beg you if they do
decide to make them hopefully they can
condense them more and make them more
appealing as films so guys have you read
the books let me know what we think of
the books below if you have seen this
film let me know you thought of the film
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]
[Applause]